taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two foods gonna fight but only one food
can be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to the mic i'm talking taste buds
buddies it's the taste buds podcast
we're debating food we're arguing food
as usual i'm joe
and i will remain sal good for you
good for you it's a good way to remain
yes yeah
romaine romaine that made me think of
salad salad salad salad
salad romaine two people call me salad
as a nickname
really yeah i got a lot of nicknames
with sal involved in some way
uh and salad uh is two people call me
salad but
really yeah who calls you that can you
say my buddy jay miller calls me salad
and uh i'm blanking on the other person
but it's only been two because i was it
resonated with me i was like wow
only one other person calls me that i
feel high school with a kid named jay
miller
oh well it's about the same guy
obviously
you know do you know steve smith it's
common names that we're getting
you want to bust my stones right out of
the gate isn't that the point i just
we have won today that i
think is gonna be a sleeper because
while i don't often feel that there's
tension between the two items
i do think that it is a classic matchup
would you agree
i agree it's a 100 classic matchup uh
i often in my mind
when i'm in a grocery hit these two
drinks against one another
really and i say that that sounds a
little more adversarial than i wanted to
but i certainly think there's a reason
they exist in the same section right
next to one another
uh i think there's a reason that you see
them both at a lot of your barbecues and
outdoor events in the summertime
uh and i think there's a reason they're
often mentioned in the same breath
uh we're talking of course people of
lemonade
and iced tea
two classic drinks i mean classics god
only knows when these were invented
i think these two things you think
summertime
refreshment you think barbecue cookouts
picnics
you think boardwalks you think americana
right you think porch rocking chair you
know you think
childhood you think lemonade stand
holy [ __ ] yeah lemonade was invented in
1630 well i believe it because it is
lemon and water
iced tea was invented in 1904
lemonade is that much older when was t
invented because he was invented in like
two t has been around since bc
no so you think it took them that long
to make the leap
from letting the tea get cold i mean tea
was invented in 2737
which is a year that is so old it sounds
like the future
was invented tea was invented what
you're in
we're in 2020. tea was invented
5 000 years ago iced tea
was invented 110 years ago so it took
them 4
900 years to be like i'll sip that
it says here an american merchant uh
often given credit with the invention
his name is richard
belk belky kinden el kinden uh
at the world's fair in st louis he
brought it and he was selling
this is great he was sampling and
selling hot tea at his fare booth
but few fair growers were in the market
for hot beverages in the intense summer
heat
but it took them until nine that
that experience didn't happen until 1904
someone was like you want a tea
and like what you want to bug out even
harder it's hot as hell out here i don't
want a hot drink
can you throw some cubes in there you
want to freak out even harder oh
when was iced coffee invented i bet that
was like
that was like august
iced coffee but iced coffee took the
role by 1840 what
iced coffee was invented before iced tea
everyone drinks iced tea you have to be
a coffee drinker to drink iced coffee
anybody drinks iced tea there's a child
walking around with an iced tea right
now
i swear to you i would have i i
would have lost i would have bet
the belongings of my the contents of my
bank account
that it was not invented any time before
1993.
me too i thought it came out with like
grunge music
me too i swear to god it came out of
seattle when starbucks was invented
that's what i really really thought iced
coffee i never hear about like my
grandfather being like oh i love that
every morning my grandpa was up steep
and coffee and never had an iced coffee
the original okay the zagren a cold
sweetened
iced coffee beverage that originated in
algeria circa 1840 has been described by
locals
as the original iced coffee it was
prepared with coffee syrup and cold
water
frozen coffee beverage beverages limited
slush
are documented in the 90s okay so so so
uh
uh mikey right google when was
modern iced coffee invented because
there's something different i want to
get as many votes as possible 1920. so
the way we know it's okay
but that's still 80 years ago it's only
15 years after ic
i'm gonna hit this right now okay best
starting the debate
better beverage lemonade iced tea i just
want to get because i just want to
okay start get get the time in better
beverage limited ic i don't want to
you know i don't want to do what's
happened to me in the past which is
you know you call it and then one second
later the entire time
you realize that after i agree with you
you can just do the thing you don't have
to keep explaining it right
are you wearing that because i've
noticed a trend in our friendship where
i'll say sure and you'll go c because
i'll go no no sure
but but i just want to keep it i think
i'm trying to make sure that you're okay
with it
um no no no no no no there's what you
say and what you put forth
and then there's you know contact uh
there's a
sub subtext the fact that you're
insinuating now that i'm a liar of some
kind
well we know you're a lie that's it
that's been proven what episode is this
is this episode 13 that's improved on 12
other episodes no this is episode 12.
or it's 12th in the who knows we've done
12. i don't know if this will come out
as 12 but this is the 12th one we've
recorded
you are correct yeah sure um yeah
so wild to me so and also too why these
are pit
i don't mean to step around no please
why these are pitted together yeah or
against one another whatever
the arnold palmer is the mixture of the
two yeah so these these are a
hand-in-hand drink
let's see when the arnold palm and i'm
assuming arnold palmer is the one who
used to order at the restaurant a lot
where it's got to be right
it is wild that he would go to a place
and ask for that and it became named
1960s so to recap
lemonade invented in 14 1630
1640 iced coffee
wait no ice no tea was invented 5 000
years ago
yeah lemonade is uh was invented in
paris in 1630.
yeah iced tea was 1904 iced tea was 1904
the first person to combine it wasn't he
a golfer
arnold palmer famous golfer 1960s
56 years later he was like let me
combine the two with a beverage that
they'd already been putting lemon into
and he was the first guy to go you know
you could just combine
combine the lemonade would any you you'd
say there's a camp out there that would
argue that the arnold
the arnold palmer is better than the two
of them individually
you wouldn't say that i would but you
would say there are people i would say
there's a camp out there and i get that
argument 100
i mean it's it is the best of both
worlds i think j my buddy james murray
orders
arnold palm polymers a lot there's
things that he loves and he loves that
he's one of the only people i know that
is always like do you have arnold
palmer's which
essentially i think that i guess you
could ask that if you have them but
he should really ask do you have
lemonade on i don't know well i i
i've i've had a many a meal with our
buddy steve byrne mutual friend dear
friend of ours
he always gets arnold palmer's is he uh
i've seen it i've seen this guy i've
never seen somebody order it so much
arnold palmer challenges my new york
um upbringing in my accent it's easy if
i didn't
if i every time i've said it so far i
have to literally tell my brain to say
arnold palmer how do you want to say it
if i just say it quick
arnold palmer arnold palmer arnold
it's actually a little bit of a tongue
say arnold palmer five times fast i
think we just invented arnold palmer
arnold palmer number two arnold palmer
[ __ ] yeah it's tough did anyone know
that arnold palmer was a
say like i've heard of like toy boat
can't say that five times faster toy
boat toy boat toy boat toy boat
toy boat that's pretty good
toy boat toy boat toy boat is a tough
one toy boat
toy boat toy boat you were you were
concentrating i didn't go it's super
fast
toy boat toy boat toy boat toy boy
[Laughter]
yeah arnold palmer arnold palmer right
arnold palmer
can't get out of arnold palmer after
arnold palmer you can't do it two times
fast arnold palmer
arnold palmer oh yeah no this is a thing
look there's people doing it on youtube
yeah we broke it here first i thought
there's a lady doing it oh [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] yeah put up that seven
second video to show that you could say
it three times slow
arnold palmer arnold palmer arnold
palmer arnold palmer
arnold palmer well he did it wow i
shocked myself
but you you could not and neither could
i you could not go a hair
faster than that no it would be but
arnold palmer arno
if i don't pronounce the rs and i just
sound like i have marbles in my mouth
it's arnold palmer arnold you know what
i'm done with it
i'm done with it this is about iced tea
and lemonade yeah all right
uh now let's get into this sal let's
tell the good people at home
what side you're choosing there's no
doubt both are refreshing and
there's no doubt that both of them have
their merits and they have their times
when one might be better
than the other but without a doubt and i
think that we know this the front runner
and the
and and the person i have to decide with
is the iced tea
uh it's more popular it comes in more
varieties and you know what
let's throw out varieties let's do that
right away i don't want to have that
argument with you
a classic iced tea tea cold
okay sweetened or unsweetened will you
allow me that
because it really is consumed exactly
the same both ways
i'll allow you sweetener i would have
allowed you the flavors man i don't eat
the flavors i'll go sweetened
unsweetened cause there's flavored
lemonades i don't i don't mess around
with them but they're out there but
lemonade is
essentially sugar-based every time so
then sweetened iced tea okay sweetened
iced tea
i should have wrote that in the polls
it's fine i don't think anybody's
words matter i don't think anybody does
people are gonna be like and they're
gonna
i know what they're gonna do you don't
know
i have a little sweet tea maybe or
they're gonna say i hate
sweet tea counts it's what's icing i
know but i'm saying i
i you know the leniency i give you i
know
i'm agreeing with you because before i
said um
yeah before we i just don't want people
to to to
latch on to every single type of iced
tea here's the thing iced tea
is is gonna win okay lemonade i'm going
with i'm now i'm choosing lemonade
the all-time classic because nothing to
me
lemonade yeah nothing to me
is more refreshing than a cold glass
yeah i i will tell you what i do with a
lemonade who was he doing when he did
that
paul jones elvis elvis yeah we got to
win this race
he could sing his lines was a joke okay
so here's what i do with a lemonade
already one of my favorite things to do
at home
uh is taco night i love to do taco night
so i go and i get a box of ortega maybe
el paso shells
okay i get a pound and a half of ground
meat tacos haven't been on the docket
against anything let's get tacos down on
the docket because tacos is a good one
yeah so i get a pound and a half of
ground meat i get some tomatoes i get a
bag of
of shredded extra sharp cheddar cheese
she's gonna take us to the taco night
and a hot sauce
chalupa we time these episodes so they
could be
bite-sized 30 to 40 minutes ask me again
if i mean what i'm saying
please i'm so sorry go ahead please
continue on the ingredients
in the taco
man you're cruising for a bruising today
holy [ __ ]
yeah just get stitches all right then i
get a whole
jug of simply lemonade
have you had it yes i have had it i
gotta stop myself from drinking you're
gonna have you're gonna get
diabetes why i didn't say i drank it all
once
oh stop i mean the way you the dramatic
pain is
insinuated that you drink the 64 ounces
with your tox
i i get that i don't get the 64 ounce
when i get that one the regular size one
and i have to get a whole jug well
that's what a jug is sal look
no that's 59 ounces at least okay i get
the one that's the gallon
you you're not getting it you're not
getting a 16 ounce i get the
you get the bottle yeah but you're
getting the one that could
pour four or five glasses yes and you're
drinking that all
right no no i just said i'm not drinking
at all hold on can you pull up the
nutrition contents on this
simply lemonade please i will drink
about three glasses of it while i eat
the tacos
three glasses 160 calories in an eight
ounce serving
maybe two glasses maybe two 40 carbs
42 carbs 40 sugars sorry i didn't say it
i did it as my diet day
i know it's a special night i have 120
sugars
well you know what sweet iced tea is
going to be right in that same camp yeah
i can't i can't point is nothing tastes
better against the spicy taco that i
chop up jalapenos and chili peppers and
put it through
okay and then with a with a cool glass
of lemonade
that's great but in the in the case of
lemonade v
iced tea that does no one anything
another reason lemonade's better
yeah he can mix it with things it's a
great thing don't do the thing
but mike just looks right at me because
he's doing the thing he argues against
where he's banning into something else
mike do we not both do
does it more who does it more who argues
against it harder and then does it more
and just just smirks it off in our faces
about it
i got a hint for you mike's silence is
very telling
you can mix it with alcohol iced tea i
love it iced tea you could get it on
sweden you can get it sweetened
whatever mood you're in for you get it
by the way iced tea
often is sweetened with lemon or lemon
wedge
so it has elements of the lemonade in it
itself iced tea you can buy pre-packaged
from a manufacturer or you can make it
fresh most people
since 1600 1400
have had tea on hand 14 30 16 30.
the genius of an iced tea is if you want
iced tea
most likely you can go right into your
cabinet take some tea bags and not only
can you have iced tea
you could have freshly brewed iced tea i
think more people have tea bags at the
ready in their homes then they have a
satchel of lemons
and it takes a lot more effort and pulp
and ratio to sugar to lemonade well to
make a lemonade
lemonade is messy it's acidic it's
sticky it's getting all over then you're
dumping in sugar
it's hard it's getting older way more
people are making you think
iced tea is not sticky when you spill
i'm taking tea bags i'm throwing them in
a thing and i'm mixing them and letting
them steep a little bit
squeeze i'm ready to go you see if i
wanted to make it fresh you think
squeezing in
a lemon half over a pitcher is somehow
you're not squeezing a lemon half not if
you're making real lemonade my friend a
lemon half
a pitcher of lemonade you'll probably
need to yield will yield about
i don't know what maybe 10 lemons i'm
saying each one i'm squeezing
i cut it in half you got to cut in half
10 lemons you're squeezing 20 half
lemons
into a pitcher to to net out you know
what i'm
i'm taking five teaspoons i'll give you
this i'm throwing it in i'm just waiting
and i'm forgetting it good morning joe
hi
jeez you're eating that cereal like it's
your job
you know the best part what's that
it's grain free yeah
soy freak yeah low carb yeah and gmo
free
also gluten free keto friendly has zero
sugar
11 grams of protein and only three net
carbs
per serving i bet i know what you're
thinking right
that probably tastes terrible
it tastes great it's magic spoon
cereal is back baby you can eat it
guilt-free taste it
before i taste it is everything okay at
home what is going on with you
things are bad at home which is why i'm
eating cereal all day for every meal
but at least now i can eat it with a
clean conscience
coming in four delicious flavors fruit
blueberry
cocoa and frosted i love all four but my
favorites are fruit and blueberry i
gotta be honest
i love this stuff i gave up cereal years
ago because there was no way to eat it
without having to
die and that's the truth or you had to
eat something that tasted like
like like wood chips or you had to eat
some kind of thing that was supposed to
be good but didn't taste good
this tastes great magic spoon has done
it i don't know how they did it they're
miracle workers they did it i'm being
serious magicspoon.com taste buds that's
where you're gonna go
magicspoon.com taste buds once you're
there you're gonna enter the promo code
taste buds you're gonna get five dollars
off a variety pack
variety pack containing four flavors
cocoa frosted
fruity blueberry boom and if you don't
like it for whatever reason
which you will love it i promise you
that but if you don't
100 happiness guarantee for any reason
you're not satisfied they're gonna
refund your money
no questions asked i even like the name
i love the name yeah
magic spoon it's just fun i like it yeah
yeah so
uh we we said try it out let us know how
you like it yeah that's it
god bless go to go to magicspoon.com
taste buds and use the promo code once
you get there taste buds
to save five bucks on that variety pack
thanks a lot gang
hello everybody uh thanks for uh
listening to tastebuds
we have uh to talk about a sponsor of
ours called headspace
i am a basket case most of the time i am
neurotic person
i worry i maybe got it from my
grandparents passed down to my parents
but i uh think i'm always about to die
way to pass the buck
yeah i mean the blame game is a tricky
one as any good therapist will tell you
yeah
that's right you don't want to get in
this head you know what i'm saying but i
have found meditation to actually truly
be something that helps me in my life
and headspace is just that it's a guided
meditation app it's really easy to use
if you join using the taste buds promo
code you're gonna get a free month
which gives you back access to their
entire library a free month you could
try it
a hundred times a day for 30 days
straight and see if you like it
yeah and i like uh headspace in
particular because
number one it's helped a lot of people i
know which is great
but uh i just like the variety of stuff
they offer i like
especially that they have that
three-minute sos meditation
where if you're really in a jam like yes
which i use all the time or if you need
help falling asleep which i often do
uh you know i mean sometimes uh you know
headspace provides a service for me that
it's like
hey maybe you don't go to sleep to the
stephen king audiobook tonight
maybe maybe you do something that'll
give you some better dreams
this is what meditation can do right
reduce stress improve sleep boost focus
just improve your overall sense of
well-being um
it's backed by 25 published studies on
its benefits 600
000 5 star reviews and over 60
million downloads so obviously this is a
proven track record
you deserve to feel better headspace is
meditation made simple go to
headspace.com
tastebuds that's headspace.com tastebuds
for a free one-month trial with access
to the entire
library of meditations yep that's it do
it for
space do it for you
and you got stuck there now you see what
you did you went out on a limb
and you just started saying some some
you started making up slogans on your
own you got
brash you got real brash at the end we
were going smooth
and then you said i'm going to take the
bull by the horns and i'm just going to
start throwing out slogans
like you could do better than every
advertising agency
people have conferences about about
slogans and you were like i'm going to
take the reigns
and you said two and the third one was a
charm and we came to a screeching halt
i want to say something to wrap this up
yes if we were on a limb
i with all my being would want to push
you off of it and watch you
fall down to hurt yourself somebody
needs headspace but i would listen to
headspace
so i didn't do that and instead i just
wish you well
on your part of the limb so you just go
to your part of the limb
and i'll stay on mine and we'll both
listen to headspace headspace.com
tastebuds sal joe you listen to a lot of
music don't you
i do i do too and i want to talk about
some great earbuds because i'm tired of
paying tons of money for my earbuds
and then i go yeah however
raycon earbuds i'm going
and then there's something we know about
it's buds isn't it that's right buddy
these earbuds that raycon is giving i
mean they're they're they're
so affordably priced they're such high
quality
they sync immediately with your phone
which i love there's no
ridiculousness in trying to get them
hooked up or to get them to work or
anything
and they're built to last they are
they're built to perform anywhere at any
time meaning that
they are water and sweat resistant
construction and the bluetooth like you
said
seamlessly because i i will tell you
something i i had buds in the past
and i can sit there over and over trying
to sink and i have to disconnect
and sync and they're dropping and
they're not and this takes all of that
out of it and the best part is raycon
makes great
sound accessible to everyone
that's important these days you know the
audacity is some of these earbuds
out there you know like oh can you
afford
us are you part of our clique raycon is
making them affordable for everybody
these wireless earbuds are starting at
half the price of other premium
audio brands so correct me if i'm wrong
they're already starting at a half price
and raycon's offering 15 off of
all of their products for our listeners
if you go to
buy raycon dot com slash taste buds
that's it you'll get 15
off your entire order from raycon feel
free to grab a pair
that's it it's fifteen percent off at
buy rate raycon dot com slash taste
butts
grab a pear and a spare earbuds taste
buds
i have a juicer so i i you know i have i
have a fruit juice
this is going out worldwide and you know
not everyone has a juicer most people
don't have juices i'm talking about a
manual juice squeezer that you use to
get like fresh lime juice or whatever i
have one of those you put that right
over the pitcher you scream no i agree
with you
it is a little bit messier fine uh and
also there are a few things i like
better than an ice cold
lemon snapple i love iced tea don't get
me wrong
but i'll tell you another wonderful
benefit
of lemonade no caffeine so if you want
to barrel down a pitcher of simply lemon
on a night because you feel like it and
you're just in that kind of mood never
mind the caffeine but you're going to
you're going to get 300 grams of sugar
in you from the lemonade
come on who's gonna be hopped up on
sugar sugar is six
sugars worse who's amped up from sugar
first of all i'll
go on further i've never had more than
one glass of lemonade
at a time because one glass is all
anyone can handle
it's a sugary delightful treat it's a
sugary delightful treat
for about eight to 16 gulps and then
you're like whoa
my system is in shock i just downed just
a just a cup of sugar
and it was fine but enough it's the same
amount of sugar as an iced tea
it doesn't play the same but also what
do you mean it doesn't but also
unsweetened iced tea and you just said i
was allowed to have unsweetness you can
argue as popular
then i'll argue diet lemonade that
doesn't have as much sugar please
because that's a that's a healthy turd
diet lemonade
really nobody gives a [ __ ] about a diet
really nobody gives a [ __ ] about it
really you talk to me about if someone
is
is an advocate for lemonade and lemonade
is their jam
they they would say shame if you said
would you like a diet
those are the same people that prefer
sweet tea over lemonade
where you're drinking it's like they
melted a chocolate bar inside the iced
tea and they drink that down
as they rock back they had to go pink
with the lemonade
i think lemonade's wonderful you got a
problem with pink lemonade
i just think that it's also just too
much i've never had more than one glass
of pink lemonade
i could drink i could drink uh
unsweetened iced tea until the cows come
home
there's something an iced tea has a
little something for everybody could not
an iced tea has a little something under
sweetened iced unsweetened iced tea
after a glass and a half of unsweetened
iced tea it tastes like your drink it
tastes
bitter it almost has a uranium if you
like that or not
it almost has like a cat urinate it
doesn't taste like
your teeth at some point my point is how
much sugar is in sweetened iced tea mike
versus lemonade
my point is this the iced tea is
versatile it's versatile many ways let
me name them
if i don't want any sugar i could have a
an unsweetened iced tea it's a classic
thing
we know right now that people picked up
on that because if you go to look at it
for an iced tea in the store
right next to it is the unsweetened iced
tea it's as popular you said that you
said
you should have written sweetened iced
tea in the poll
you said that you should have written
that no but i would now you're making an
argument against
i wouldn't have necessarily argued
against sweet and iced tea i'm arguing
for iced tea
when i say iced tea people think all
right i'll have it either this way this
way when i say lemonade
it's really like one way to have
lemonade right so iced tea
if you don't want the sugar you don't
have to have it if you want it you get
the boost if you want some caffeine you
get that
if you want cold refreshment you get
that i won't get into the flavors of
iced tea but there's many
lemonade has one flavor it's just right
there's raspberry iced tea there's
strawberry steak
i'm sorry there's raspberry lemonade
there's strawberry lemonade there's
watermelon lemonade
but when we had it on the street when we
had on the street this summer
that strawberry frozen margarita and i
said trust me get this from this place
it was good and i finished about
two-thirds of it and i was like i have
to throw this away i cannot drink this
sugar but you said you said to me this
is delicious
you get but i'm not saying that a
lemonade isn't delicious
you get a water ice you get a cherry
lemon water ice
that tastes like lemonade it tastes like
cherry here we go
the lemon ice is the crepe of the
lemonade
i'm just telling you what it tastes like
i'm not saying it supports the argument
25 sugar oh that's okay that's depends
i mean yeah this is 22.25 that's going
to vary
it's taste it really is to taste but my
point being though
iced tea is also more versatile in the
fact that nope
no matter what lemonade can we pause it
we just cut out
it's chris what do you mean who would
that be it's your other podcast
[Laughter]
three minutes just within the three
minutes of when he said he'd be here
lemonade you're talking about diversity
lemonade bubble gum
there's lemonade flavored things there
is no iced tea
flavored thing i'm sorry i have ocd can
you take the pillow point and just put
it away from me please
i mean this is a buddy i have i have a
what do you call that ocd
yeah yeah i just said it yeah i'm all
over the truck because it frazzles me it
does
if you could just bend it down so that
the point is not coming no no no
look at me there look at me baby babe
look i like it like derosa look at me
just push it that way i don't want it
just see how it is like this just
just push it i don't want it down i want
it pointing up like that
no and then there's no point no yeah but
i'm telling you it's going to affect me
well sounds like you need to grow up
you know what i do when i grow up i have
iced tea over lemonade because lemonade
is a children's drink
okay lemonade i think of lemonade i
think of a kid
that has two teeth missing that needs 15
cents in a bad way
that's what i think of when i think of
lemonade sure you could attach it to the
nostalgia of someone having a lemonade
stand
and the kid it's all a cutesy cute
lemonade stand i forgot about that
let's talk about an american tradition
nobody i could be sitting on my porch
rocking back and forth with a glass of
iced tea
oh you mean like a slave owner is that
what you mean real nice reference
did you just make a plantation reference
what's the matter with you sorry
everybody who has a porch has a
plantation
rocky going back and forth with a sweet
tea i mean that's everyone right today
in the south right now
yelling at people to work harder i know
where you were going with that
uh lemonade stand no kids ever had an
iced tea stand
there's a lemon the lemonade thing could
take a [ __ ] it's the biggest scam going
the parents put the portrait you think
the child at
three is like mommy i want to produce
lemonade and sell it at low wages
great moments of my childhood was having
a lemonade stand it was so scary it
doesn't make it a better beverage
there's a reason there's a reason it's
the beverage for the
child's hog wash drink there there is no
iced tea stand
there is no iced tea flavored popsicle
it's a lemonade flavored popsicle
nominated i want iced tea in my house i
drink unsweetened
there you go i see 50 cents iced tea
stand i still haven't remembered
remember sweet tea
please please make note please make note
mike
please make note as he calls me a
hypocrite when he goes
if you google something you'll find it
please make note of that
okay but he wanted me to admit into
evidence
ham and cheese pancakes and you said if
you google it you'll find it and you
found it
so then why can't i tell you there's an
iced tea stand now it's not good enough
this is my point your boy is a hypocrite
your boy joey hypocrite roses
is a hypocrite that's what he does all
right what he does people
you tell him what he does how you're
feeling after three three
children that you tell me how you're
about to curb
[Music]
yeah you tell me how you're feeling
after three glasses on
unsweetened iced tea it's like drinking
it's stronger than crosstalk swear to
god i swear to god i swear to you and i
really believe this
if i drink three glasses of lemonade i'm
liable to punch
you i'm liable i asked you how you feel
after you drink three glasses of
unfortunately
fine it's more caffeine than coffee it
doesn't really affect me
that doesn't make it a better you have a
super power so it does this so now it's
better
when you finish three tall glasses of
lemonade with your tacos i feel great
are you not just
are you just then bending over and
shooting stuff out of your body
let me tell you how much i'm not ready
because this is what i do i finish the
glasses i finish my tacos
and i do what i always do i turn i swing
my feet up onto the couch
i lay back and i go right into a nice
without position you can't you can't
inject yourself with that much sugar man
think of the lemon on its own
sucks the lemon is a good complement
yeah the lemon juice
nobody takes a bite out of it a tea leaf
on its own and tell me it's great
point taken yeah exactly come on but my
point is
that you could buy no joke you can go to
your
your local area greater area costco and
you could buy
for one dollar you could probably buy
300 tea bags
you could live off of iced tea for a
buck
you got to go to the store and buy fresh
produce 10 lemons to yield a pitcher
you're up there cutting lemons squeezing
lemons if you sit in your eyes
stickiness on your hands if you want the
worst success if you want the worst kind
of iced tea you can do that
if you want iced tea that's enjoyable
you got to buy sugar
you're going to have to buy some lemons
it's so involved iced tea i'm dropping a
tea bag
i'm setting it up for getting it but
you're not hitting you're not hearing me
i'm just saying
what right for me i always look at the
dish from every component
i think iced tea is way more accessible
and versatile i can make it in my house
right now even if i didn't have
pre-made iced tea i can go downstairs i
could drop a tea bag which i have plenty
of
how long it takes to make cold tape are
you out of your mind you're going to
make sun tea
let's just make something let's call it
20 minutes did you ever make sun tea
i'll ask you a question do you ever make
something i don't know what suntan it
takes
it's when you put tea into a pitcher
with water
and you leave it in the sun to to to
become tea in the sun it takes
all okay old man withers i don't do that
all right delicious what i'm telling you
is that if i
a freshly brewed iced tea right now i
can make it happen at an affordable
price in a quick amount of time
no effort in cold water
well i could brew it in like a brew it's
deeper so you're going to make it hot
and then you're going to cool it off
what do you need to make lemonade you
need a very sharp knife you need
10 pieces of fresh produce where are you
getting this 10 from
i want to see hold on because if you
want i want to say you want a pitcher
look up recipe pitcher lemonade
i want to see how many lemons it is i'm
going to bet you at six
i'm going to bet you you press it right
there no no right there old-fashioned
lemonade recipe no no go up
you're right there look no no the link
old-fashioned
what do we got that six lemons boom
boom it feels good to be right for that
recipe sure but
okay i'm sorry but i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry sorry i'm sorry
knock on someone's door cold call them
not gonna go outside
walk down my block knock on the door and
go excuse me
could you make me fresh lemonade right
now they might go well no i don't have
enough if you say if you say could you
make me iced tea they'll go i can make
you unsweetened
that's psychotic you have to if you want
i'm saying accessibility when i take
into a dish
edition to account i take in the scope
of of what it brings to the table what
it's all about
i have accessible cheap iced tea at the
ready at all times
with no effort if you wanted to make
yourself fresh lemonade right now
you've got to get in the car now you're
leaving a carbon footprint now you're
leaving a car
then you got to go and you've got you're
reaching you've got to go to the store
now you got to feel like
you're ready there's duds now you've got
to figure it out
you've got to slice them open squeeze
them use me that the superior takes
effort
and you can't buy three pounds of it for
78. i hope
i hope you don't have a paper cut
anywhere on you i hope you don't close
your eyes i hope you have
goggles i hope you have safety cogs i
love that your argument is
you can get a ton of it for nothing that
that speaks to the quality of it i hate
to break through that is not true and
you know that
sure it is that has been proven over and
over from time about any product
more expensive does it mean better we
know that that's what i'm no no people
what i'm saying people people lived off
of t tea has provided
he has provided beverages for sustenance
he has provided soothing calmness okay
that's why it's that's why
hot tea was drinking by the monks in the
hills
5 000 years ago in about 5 000 years ago
it gives
life tea is life baby you drink hot tea
of course i drink
tea i hot tea last night oh come on
swear to god hot toddy last night don't
you no
no it wasn't a house twisted joe look at
me swear to god you're telling me you're
taking me let's got teas and hot toddies
all last night
you told me downstairs i said i had hot
potties last night i didn't say last
night dude i said i made hot totties
recently okay
you know what i had a hot tea today all
right
i was given a choice call for your hot
tea i said
uh hot tea you're nuts no but you but
this is not a i'm not telling anyone
anyone who knows me i'm not i'm not i
drink hot tea on three
i'm not
we've had skim milk is my favorite first
of all it reminds me okay
every time i was not feeling well i had
a hot tea in my mind okay
every time you're just comforting hold
on a second it's
we've had the hot tea we've had the top
five beverages convo a million times
you've never mentioned hot tea and every
time we've had the top five beverages
convo
we've had it on this show once or twice
what up hot tea is always in my time
add another uh uh drink twice it's
always been in my house
second of all there are three occasions
on which i drink a hot tea
when i lose my voice when i don't feel
good
or when i go to a chinese restaurant
that's it
that's it ever three wonderful times
well every other time it's coffee and
i'm talking daily base
the most popular okay 340 million
results came up here in point eight
seconds the most popular
type of drink number one is tea when
discovering the most popular drinks in
the world oh really he has to he took
number one
very top when it's the most popular
drink in asia with billions of people
yeah of course it's number one i mean
coffee is number two coffee is very
popular
in every single every single crevice of
this
you said with pancakes and waffles i
think coffee then is actually a win
because it's it's you've got an unfair
advantage right now but we're not
arguing coffee versus tea we're arguing
iced tea
tea is an addictive versus syrup of
course let's go back to lemonade
look i this is where i'll this is my
closing argument for lemonade i don't
know where are we on time
this is my closing argument on lemonade
and i said it before and this is true
and i'll say it again i'll say it again
i think that most people would agree
with me here
i don't drink multiple glasses of
lemonade it's
just too much making this argument if
the drink was
the better drink i would be able to
drink it that's not true willy-nilly
that's not true you could say that wine
is a superior drink
for instance to vodka but you could then
say but i can only have two or three
glasses of wine
whereas a vodka soda i could drink six
because it goes down different it sits
here he settles the stomach
okay but that's but that's not an
argument but it's not an argument for a
better beverage that you need to drink
more gonna put you to bed
you can drink more of water than most
beverages it's not a better beverage
what does lemonade do it's got to be hot
it's got to be a glass
by the way why is it going to be hot hot
out no why why can't it be cold but
that's when i really
feel like i crave a lemonade all right
well that's you sal
this world doesn't revolve around you
most people
most people yeah no one no one goes to a
restaurant and says
i'll have a cheeseburger and a lemonade
they say i'll have a cheeseburger and a
coke no they don't go and say i'll get a
slice of pizza and a lemonade
and they say i'll take a slice of pizza
and a snack listen to this stretch
who the hell says give me a cheeseburger
fries and an iced tea i'll give you one
sweetener
nobody has ever said that in time let me
mic drop you you go
i love the brand simply lemonade
yeah let me talk to you about a little
bit of brown orange an apple do you ever
have simply
made from the greatest stuff on earth
yeah okay tea
yeah i love results the results are
crazy
are we going to be in for it all right
let's just go let's go i want to see
i want to see we've made the argument go
away
crow boys it's time for humble pie the
are you if you're listening right now
what are you doing
who are you what are you doing lemonade
58.2 percent
to 41.8 percent we haven't got percent
margin to lemonade bank 8 000 votes
spanked bro i won all four today hold on
this is it
i won pancakes versus waffle by a nose
hair i won
uh uh waffles is winning what's it
called was a landslide doritos was
77 and then the first one was uh was
chipwich and the classic i said what you
did today is you came to my home
what you did the last four weeks what
what you've done the last
handful of weeks as you've walked in
here and you placed
a one single bet to win on seabiscuit
no that's what you did what i did you
came in here every week and you placed a
dollar to win on sea biscuits you
you did nothing else agreed we did
nothing else at the beginning
i could choose you know i could choose
the most popular thing ever
out of your mind with the underdog
things i as you
bragged about the the text you got from
the great bill burr
texted me and said i didn't say it i
brought it up when you brought up
someone said
hates america because i'm always picking
the underdogs
and now you're going to come to me and
say that i've been watching
i've been watching bill burr and his
point of view
for a good 20 years and i put stock in
it okay
my point is is he said that i was
picking a contrary cookie
at the beginning earlier today we when
we talked when we brought that up with
one of the other episodes
okay right now now you're gonna say that
i came in here and bet easy wins
you think lemonade versus ice cream no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no i give you this
completely
i'm shocked i bow down it's significant
it's over a little over eight percent
i thought that uh iced tea was the
favorite so to come in and win by eight
percent
i i gotta give it to you completely i
will say though i
don't know where people's heads are at i
don't know where the heads are i'll tell
you where they're at
that lemonade is better it's not it's
not rocket science
here's one here's what i don't
understand if lemonade
iced tea gives you kidney stones plus
it's gross
okay allison iced tea when i when i'm
thirsty lemonade
spiked with absolute citron seriously
i'd rather drink pee
well you don't know who might be our
winner that might be our winner though
i know but that might be our winner we
don't know if they're they're railing
against what beverages i'm saying that
still might be our win because it's
funny
yeah it's just funny iced tea but only
if it's made southern style which is
brewed in direct sunlight
sun tea baby wait scroll up a little bit
what was that pole there
salvo cannon versus iced tea
all right that's that might be our
winner i gotta be honest man
i am shocked that lemonade beetles both
are gross i'm
shocked a guy says uh but why is
lemonade not more popular
you know how often it is that i'm
sitting around someone at a restaurant
or a dinner table
and when the bed when the lady says what
can i get y'all to drink
nobody says i'll have a lemonade look at
this one
stop playing lemonade y'all got
you y'all ain't drinking too he right
what the hell the right okay it's major
typo on that one
somebody wrote both i agree i like a
half and half
i know this is unpopular opinion but
iced tea sucks i never really liked iced
tea
hot tea is gross thank you sir at the
best of times
i can only imagine cold tea would be the
spawn of satan
holy [ __ ] that guy i don't think he's
ever had hd
uh that might be the winner god damn it
we got some good responses today
man guys i don't know what's up with you
buddies taste buddies i don't know what
the hell's up with you guys right now
all right let's pick a winner i i think
spawn of satan took
that's great all right that's our winner
folks and that's our show this was a
great throw down uh what's his name
uh that that oh her excuse me chloe
at clutch nine two at clutch nine two
follow chloe chloe
thanks for writing in that's great the
puking emoji mate takes it over the top
uh joe derosa on instagram and twitter
and come down to the joey rosa sandwich
shop at the stand in new york city
uh good the best thing you could do for
us uh
is subscribe to the no pressure network
and just share
tweet rate all those things that you do
to get some eyes on the podcast that is
the best way you can help us if you're a
fan of it
just uh just rate the podcast listen to
the podcast share the podcast if you
like it that's at taste buds
on all social platforms and then we also
have hey babe on all social platforms
uh yeah i still love you buddy i love
you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools gonna fight but only one food can
be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds